[Aplausos]
[Música]
cuál pensáis que ha sido el país más
próspero el país que más ha crecido en
sudamérica durante los últimos 40 años
tenéis 3 segundos para responder
321 exacto
he seguido muy de cerca por panamá y
uruguay chile se alza con la primera
plaza ha sido el país de sudamérica que
mejor desempeño económico y social ha
tenido durante las últimas cuatro
décadas durante este tiempo chile ha
pasado de ser uno de los países más
pobres de todo el continente a
posicionarse junto a uruguay como el
país más desarrollado y próspero de
américa latina'
desde finales del siglo 20 experimentado
un desarrollo más que notable y todos
los indicadores económicos y sociales
han mejorado desde los años 90 y gracias
a un proceso de crecimiento regular muy
habitual en la región los niveles de
producción económica de chile se ha
multiplicado casi por cuatro al tiempo
que el número de personas en situación
de pobreza se ha desplomado más de un 75
por ciento hoy chile ocupa a nivel de
américa latina' el primer lugar en el
índice de desarrollo humano de naciones
unidas- que el primer puesto en el
índice de libertad humana la segunda
plaza en el índice de prosperidad global
también el segundo puesto en el índice
de percepción de la corrupción y la
tercera posición en el índice de calidad
democrática
es decir aunque con muchos pero de los
que por cierto ya os hemos hablado en
pasados vídeos con los datos en la mano
podemos decir que chile lo ha hecho
razonablemente bien durante las últimas
décadas al menos en el contexto de
américa latina'
[Música]
sin embargo pese a ello los últimos años
no han sido particularmente buenos ni en
términos económicos ni tampoco sociales
por ejemplo entre el año 2014 y el año
2021 el pib per cápita real apenas
creció a una tasa anualizada del 0 9% un
registro muy pobre para un país que
todavía tiene que converger con los más
ricos de hecho para que os hagáis una
idea el pibe real per cápita de eeuu
creció durante exactamente el mismo
periodo de tiempo a una tasa anual de
casi el 14 por ciento esto es un 55% más
que el crecimiento registrado en chile
así que la distancia entre estos dos
países no sólo no se ha recortado sino
que se ha incrementado de forma
relevante concretamente en más de 4.600
dólares per cápita y luego desde el
punto de vista sociedad las cosas
tampoco han marchado mucho mejor durante
los últimos años el conflicto mapuche os
hemos hablado de ello hace poco quien
visual política ha incrementado su
intensidad y luego las protestas del
2019 pusieron el país patas arriba y
alimentaron una ola de violencia de una
intensidad no vista en muchísimo tiempo
algo que por cierto terminó con un
proceso constituyente y con gabriel
boric como presidente de chile pues bien
el caso es que el 4 de septiembre del
2022 los chilenos tendrán que decidir en
referéndum si aprobar o rechazar esta
nueva institución y sabéis que según las
encuestas la mayoría de los chilenos
están en contra de la propuesta si la
mayoría sigue siendo partidaria de
cambiar la constitución en vigor que
está heredada de la época de pinochet
pero están en contra del texto aprobado
por la asamblea constituyente de hecho
incluso si se llega a aprobar lo hará
teniendo a la mitad del país claramente
en contra y a una gran mayoría de los
chilenos profundamente decepcionados y
la pregunta es por qué pues bien
veámoslo
por cierto en américa latina' cada vez
que se habla de una crisis
inevitablemente surge el debate el de
dolarizar la economía queridos amigos el
dólar lleva casi 80 años ocupando una
posición hegemónica en el sistema
monetario internacional ahora bien que
supone exactamente para los eeuu que el
dólar sea la divisa de referencia
mundial a qué futuro se enfrenta la
moneda del 'tío sam' pues bien si
queréis conocer las respuestas a estas
preguntas no os podéis perder uno de los
últimos vídeos de si lo hubiera sabido
el canal de información financiera de
mucho activos con el que participamos os
dejo el enlace la descripción y dicho
esto continuamos
los grandes interrogantes de la nueva
constitución
amigos amigas el proceso constituyente
de chile está llegando a su fin la
convención terminó su trabajo y el
borrador de nueva constitución ya está
sobre la mesa ahora le toca a los
chilenos decidir si aprobarla o
rechazarla mediante referéndum pero
ahora bien que supone exactamente la
nueva carta magna porque está generando
tantas dudas entre los propios chilenos
como puede afectar al futuro económico y
político de este país pues son muchas
las críticas que se le han hecho a esta
propuesta desde ojo todos los puntos del
espectro político de chile unas críticas
que tal y como hemos visto han hecho que
a la mayoría de los chilenos simple y
llanamente el texto no les guste y como
evidentemente no podemos repasar la de
principio a fin en este vídeo en esta
ocasión lo que nos interesa es echar un
vistazo a las principales críticas
[Música]
en primer lugar la nueva constitución
define a chile con una república
solidaria de democracia inclusiva y
paritaria y también como un estado
plurinacional en el que por ejemplo se
reconocen 11 naciones indígenas es decir
como veis da la sensación de que la
constitución quiere abarcar lo todo y el
problema que tienen estas constituciones
tan amplias es que suelen llevar el
poder político a todos los rincones al
tiempo que introducen muchas muchísimas
rigideces por ejemplo en el caso de las
naciones indígenas la nueva constitución
no sólo les reconoce una cierta
autonomía lo cual puede estar bien sino
que también acepta sus propios sistemas
de justicia la pregunta es cómo se pueda
articular un estado de derecho moderno
con modelos judiciales basados en la
tradición y las viejas costumbres quiere
decir esto que no todos los chilenos se
enfrentarán al mismo modelo de justicia
pues no lo cierto es que parece que no
no hemos renunciado a ningún derecho
pero esta nueva propuesta va más allá
colisionando y pasando por encima de los
derechos de los ciudadanos no indígenas
hugo alcamán presidente de la
corporación de profesionales mapuche en
ama y ojo que esto puede tener
consecuencias muy serias
por ejemplo chile se ha convertido los
últimos años en el tercer mayor
exportador de drogas ilegales europa y
un sistema judicial tan fragmentado
podría ser utilizado por algunos grupos
criminales para obtener ventaja y ojo
que esto es algo que en cierta forma
denuncian incluso algunos líderes
indígenas fijaos siempre hemos peleado
porque en ciertos niveles podemos
resolver nuestros problemas pero en el
nivel de la policía local temas de
vecinos pero pasar a llevar la justicia
donde vamos a tener privilegios con
respecto a un chileno no indígena e
indudablemente la población se va a
rebelar contra eso hugo alcamán
presidente de la corporación de
profesionales mapuche nama de hecho la
propuesta también reconoce las
autonomías territoriales indígenas estos
territorios tendrían así libertad para
establecer regímenes económicos y
administrativos diferentes y además
mucha atención no estarían sujetos ni a
la vigilancia ni a la fiscalización del
estado
otro ejemplo la nueva constitución exige
que todos absolutamente todos los
órganos del estado estén formados al
menos por un 50 por ciento de mujeres y
haber él no me malinterpretéis está bien
favorecer la igualdad y la participación
de la mujer en todos los órganos
políticos y públicos faltaría más pero
la crítica es comprensible tiene sentido
que la constitución ni siquiera una ley
sino la propia constitución fije un
mínimo del 50% como se puede gestionar
algo así en la práctica y si no es
posible hacerlo en un determinado órgano
como encaja aquí la cuestión del mérito
y la propia igualdad que ocurre por
ejemplo con el ejército no sería acaso
mejor regular este tipo de cosas
mediante leyes pensar que las
constituciones al fin y al cabo no nacen
con un espíritu temporal no se son
preguntas cuyas respuestas no están muy
claras pero esta cuestión quizás es la
menos importante
[Música]
la nueva constitución también elimina
importantes contrapesos políticos por
ejemplo se carga el senado para
sustituirlo por una cámara de las
regiones cuyo papel la verdad genera
muchísimas dudas de hecho esto es algo
que ha sido criticado duramente por el
presidente del senado el destacado
miembro del partido socialista de chile
álvaro antonio elizalde
senado cuestiona creación de cámara de
las regiones no cumple un estándar
mínimo lo que se aprobó no cumple un
estándar mínimo de una regulación
coherente para tener un adecuado sistema
político que corresponda a nuestra
democracia expresó álvaro elizalde por
otra parte el texto también contempla la
creación del llamado consejo de la
justicia un órgano cuya función será
nombrar y cesar a los jueces y
funcionarios del sistema de justicia el
problema su composición será
mayoritariamente política es decir los
políticos notarán cesarán primera anne y
castigarán a los jueces que tienen la
misión de controlar a los propios
políticos no sé cómo poco genera dudas
pero sigamos
[Música]
la constitución también plantea grandes
cambios en el modelo económico que han
suscitado grandes críticas por ejemplo
el mecanismo de expropiación es mucho
más ambiguo respecto a las
compensaciones públicas de la
constitución en vigor no se reconoce la
propiedad intelectual industrial la
inscripción de los derechos de autor y
se pone fin al régimen de propiedad que
hasta ahora tenían los derechos de uso
de las aguas y las concesiones de
explotación minera con el nuevo texto
ambos derechos perderán su estatus de
propiedad para pasar a depender de las
decisiones administrativas de
funcionarios estatales esto supone entre
otras cosas que no se podrán vender
alquilar o utilizar para otras
actividades lo que evidentemente creará
mucha incertidumbre e inseguridad
jurídica en sectores como la agricultura
la minería o la industria que requieren
un suministro regular y abundante de
agua
y claro la pregunta es construyes algo
sobre arenas movedizas o sobre arenas
que mueva el funcionario de turno seguro
que no
pues bien en una línea muy similar el
texto le confiere al presidente la
capacidad de convocar una comisión
territorial indígena para expropiar
terrenos a lo largo y ancho de todo el
país y devolvérselos a las comunidades
indígenas un proceso que para colmo no
sería nada rápido sino que se
prolongaría indefinidamente en el tiempo
y que podría afectar a familias que
llevan siendo propietarias de las
tierras desde hace generaciones muchos
dueños de los campos no van a querer
vender porque llevan cuatro generaciones
acá dicen no seré mapuche pero soy
hombre de la tierra porque el abuelo el
nieto nacieron ahí la confrontación que
se nos viene es enorme por el tema de la
compra de tierras hugo alcamán
presidente de la corporación de
profesionales mapuche nama y por
supuesto la pregunta vuelva a ser y en
su sano juicio estaría dispuesta
invertir un solo dólar en las regiones
más susceptibles de que se produzcan
estas expropiaciones y no aún no hemos
terminado la nueva constitución parece
que sindicalizar la economía chilena
casi a niveles argentinos por ejemplo se
deja muy claro que no se podrá prohibir
ni limitar las huelgas y las acciones
sindicales algo en casos muy
extraordinarios además también se impone
la negociación colectiva sectorial y
estas organizaciones los sindicatos
incluso tendrán derecho a participar en
la toma de decisiones de las propias
siempre ojo con esta cuestión pero
seguimos
el artículo 220 da vía libre a las
regiones para crear empresas públicas y
competir con la iniciativa privada en
cuantos sectores consideren oportunos
evidentemente los políticos tienen
muchos incentivos para crear empresas
públicas aunque sea solo para crear
empleos a costa del sector privado
asimismo también permitirá que los
políticos puedan destituir por razones
políticas a los miembros que componen la
junta del banco central limitando
claramente su independencia
por último otra gran crítica es que la
constitución incluye un enorme catálogo
de derechos sociales el problema es que
además de limitar mucho la elección
política pues no deja claro cómo
pagarlos por ejemplo la nueva
constitución impone la creación de un
modelo de universidad pública y gratuita
y ojo que esto es algo que como ya vimos
en visual económico puede no ser la
panacea que muchos piensan por cierto si
aún no conoces visual económica no
olvides echar un vistazo de hecho los
datos apuntan a que la universidad
gratuita suele ser una acción regresiva
paradójicamente los mayores beneficiados
suelen ser las rentas más altas y es que
para estos casos la evidencia demuestra
que las becas generosas o la
financiación participativa suele
conllevar muchos mejores resultados pero
algo claro desde el punto de vista del
político pues no es tan atractivo así
que la nueva propuesta de constitución
excluye por completo esta posibilidad
luego otro ejemplo lo tenemos con el
artículo 54 que obliga a crear un
sistema público de pensiones lo cual
puede estar bien si hablamos de un
modelo de protección asistencial el
problema es que tal y como está
redactado el texto lo que hace es
habilitar e incluso incentivar que los
gobiernos apuesten por un sistema de
reparto o un modelo que la mayoría de
países donde opera como por ejemplo
españa está fallando estrepitosamente
básicamente porque no son sostenibles
cuando la población pues comienza a
envejecer
pues bien estos siete grupos estos siete
grandes temas en el derecho indígena las
cuotas la desaparición de contrapoderes
los cambios del modelo económico la
sindicalización el intervencionismo y
los derechos sociales no financiados
aglutinan algunas de las mayores
críticas que está recibiendo la
propuesta constitucional unas críticas
que por ejemplo han hecho que
importantes figuras incluso en el
centroizquierda se hayan opuesto a ella
este es el caso por ejemplo del ex
presidente ricardo lagos asimismo a
principios de julio un grupo de
economistas relevantes en su mayoría de
centroizquierda conocido como
convergencia transversal hizo público un
manifiesto en el que se afirmaba que la
nueva constitución podría afectar
gravemente a la estabilidad política y
económica del país poniendo incluso en
peligro su desarrollo socioeconómico y
ojo que incluso el propio gobierno de
gabriel boric ha tenido que salir al
paso prometiendo cambiar la constitución
si finalmente es aprobada para limitar
así algunos de estos puntos más
controvertidos es decir que ni el propio
gobierno de izquierdas la compra tal y
como está cinco cambios que propone
hacen el gobierno de chile al proyecto
de constitución si se aprueba el texto
no sé pero qué queréis que os diga no
parece muy serio os hemos hablado de
ello varias ocasiones en latam político
uno de los boletines que recibís los que
nos acompañéis en patrio el proceso
constituyente ha sido un auténtico
a la convención no he representado
adecuadamente los intereses del conjunto
del país a la hora de redactar su
propuesta la convención no ha trabajado
para crear un texto moderno que sea
capaz de representar el inmensa mayor
parte de los chilenos y que al mismo
tiempo sea capaz de promover una mayor
prosperidad económica que más de la
mitad de los chilenos se muestren muy
desconfiados y contrarios hacia un texto
recién elaborado supuestamente para
representar la mayoría pues dice mucho
de lo poco que se ha logrado
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas en latinoamérica
existe una auténtica obsesión por
cambiar por completo las constituciones
es algo que los últimos años se ha hecho
en venezuela en bolivia y en ecuador en
todos los casos por cierto con pobres
resultados todo esto es quizás lo que
explica que los chilenos pues parezcan
estar en contra de esta nueva
constitución pero sea como sea si algo
parece claro es que las cosas no se han
hecho bien una constitución tiene que
buscar representar a una amplia mayoría
y no solo determinados dogmas políticos
pero sea como sea llegados hasta aquí
turno para ti qué te parece esta nueva
constitución merece la pena cambiar
tanto un modelo que es relativamente ha
funcionado bien por otro que incorpora
muchas viejas recetas que siempre
fracasan si nos estás viendo desde chile
botanas a favor o en contra de esta
constitución déjanos tus respuestas por
aquí abajo en los comentarios y así
habrá más debate y por supuesto si este
vídeo se ha resultado interesante no
olvidéis darle al botón de likes
suscribiros a visar politics si es que
aún no lo habéis hecho una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]